can you tell me what scientism is
yeah i mean the short answer is that's
by scientism
we me we mean the belief that science is
all the real knowledge there is
um that's a shorthand there are lots of
different facets of it and
what which one can explore and the book
in which i explored it
most most thoroughly was actually
an earlier book called monopolizing
knowledge and and the
the purpose of that title is to is to
draw
attention to the fact that in our
society as a whole
in particular in the west today we
we have grown so reliant on
science that we that we
tend to put aside other ways of getting
to know things
and so um of course at mit we are
focused on science and we do
um focus on it very much but the truth
is
that there are many ways of getting to
know things in our world
know things reliably in our world and a
lot of them are not
science so scientism in my view is a
terrible intellectual
error it's to be it's the belief that
somehow the methods of science as we've
developed them with ex
you know experiments and and in the end
they it relies
particularly upon reproducibility in the
world
and on a kind of clarity that comes from
measurements
and mathematics and related types of
of skills those powerful though they
are for finding out about the world
are not all the knowledge do not give us
all the knowledge we
we have and there's many other forms of
knowledge
and the illustration that i usually use
um to to try to help people to think
about this is to say well look let's
think about human history i mean to what
extent can
human history be discovered
scientifically the answer is essentially
it can't
because and the reason is because human
history is not reproducible you can't do
reproducible experiments or observations
and
and go back and you know try it over
again it's
it's a one-off thing you know the
history is full of unique events
and and so you you know you you you
can't hope to do history
using the methods of science yeah i mean
in
in some sense history is a story of
miracles i mean they don't have to have
to do with god it's just uniqueness is
anyway unique events
these unique events and that science
doesn't like that because it's
uh unique events but they're very
definition and not
reproducible
you